here I have to mess with this cut off
later actually can I just real
quick
nope let's see do I have H no I don't
have any margin on this all right I'll
fuss with the green screen
later oops
now we're back
though see how far I can pull this
before it gets in the
shot there we go um
Xander love the reskin never would have
figured out the permute thing yep very
very common screw up I knew to look for
it because I've debugged this exact
thing probably at least 100
but one of my
yep pretty much that
uh create channel for stream discussions
policy look at
that doesn't look
passible
though oh it does
decent give you a puffer for
that BL
blob very
nice yesterday
uh problem with normal is that it
assumes single modal
new M here is going
well so
uh I guess what do we do here we look
at Xander m a little bit or we look at
bets M I'm trying to
think let's look what PRS we've got open
I have a ton of time now I kind of just
wanted to test out this uh this new
setup to see see if I like this chair
here for my desk I'm sitting down a
little bit
low well that's
fine uh what am I
doing welcome YouTube
folks so we've
got code ball
no other PRS open or
environments so I think what we do is we
play with Xander end and uh we get this
to a spot that we're happy
with this a cab
car Let's uh let's get to some
code see a message about action clipping
offer should
support for continuous
think I could use a standard network if
I just took one small obnoxious thing
out of his observation
space but then it wouldn't be able to
tell if it's carrying anything
I'm trying to think what I want to do
with Xander's
policy cuz
like I almost just want to mess with it
and like
add add a
channel
right yeah cuz it's kind of slow as
well I don't know how much time I have
to screw with it at the moment but we'll
try some
stuff we're going to get rid of this one
plus
um this goes to
uh times five I
believe is that how we do
enough how's the policy work in
this make linear lstm
oh I forgot I don't have a conf policy
for
funny so I guess we can leave
it we could leave it like this for now
and just
do I'm five this would be pretty easy to
to update as
well um observation space should not be
float we'll mess with that later though
I think this is a major
issue this is using like way too much
data so let's mess with this now
actually
like so the thing that's bothering me is
that you technically don't want to one
hot it in the environment you want to
one hot it in the
policy it's a
nitpick it does have implications for
bandwidth
now and then we'll do
compute observations
we'll try this I just wanted to add a
carrying Channel
already let's see if this
works okay so that does build we need to
change the
observations this is char
okay and then the only thing we got to
do is
OBS they're no longer
floats I could actually you know what I
could do is I could make it a signed
Char yeah maybe we'll make it a signed
char
go now it'll allow us to keep the
negative
know1 okay so it's on 1 0 negative 1
this is actually
fine totally
fine all I have to do is I changed this
from uate to
yeah it is Char is signed yes
right I think I'm
fine we'll see shortly but I think I'm
correct
here we have to update the network as
well
I think it's literally this network
right here isn't
it oh look uh this has one hot in it
so let's try
this this is five
pannels and this is Yep this is
I do need to go get this line that I
wrote
andom channels
it's going to be
remute no longer need one
hot return the
network
cool I believe I can get rid of
this whole thing
now obviously I'm not going to push this
without uh seeing if it works just as
well if not
better I bet we will be able to get this
thing working
cleanly inputs
type
yes that is
fair
while I forgot
track let's do that
track uh while I wait for this I think
we'll go get our puffer friend
back there he
is
[Music]
transform you can go right over
here
go I thought I had a better version of
him um this one has like a little
artifacting but we'll leave him for
now how's this
doing hard to say so
if not we'll have to do some data
examination the M also appears to have
some speed issues we will look into
those and just about everything else
that we need to do
today I'd like to get a network and C
deployed to this so we can put this onto
the
website that would be
ideal episode return is way
higher uh which is
was this is the 100 one right here
right why is the episode return so
low we'll let that run and then we'll
see what I could have possibly changed
this episode reward
looks actually looks correct to me it
looks like it was wrong
before but now it doesn't appear to
train when it did train
before
H is it increasing it is actually
increasing though which is
odd you see it's got this like steady
increase to
too well I could just that could be the
observations totally being messed up
though let me
four and then this is the fifth one
right ooh hold
on plus one I think this is missing a
plus
uh it's common like if you mess with the
observation bases to just be writing
data in the wrong
spot so I think there that was like
misaligning the
folks if we can get a uh a nice clean
policy trained on this then what I will
do is I will Port it to see and then
upload it to the website so we can
actually see this thing
online okay so immediately this is run
is way
better how think Xander's going to
be it's like yeah this is this is what
you can just do with your
instantly this is actually even slower
than I think it should be I think it'll
be way better after hyper pram sweep
interestingly it seems to be fluctuating
a
bit that could totally just be hyper
prams
though yeah there we go
curious how it's going to uh the end
behavior if it's going to actually
get the near 20 or if it's going to
fiddle out around
here I can always just increase the
episode length by like 20 steps
stuck Xander will be happy with this
either
way does seem to be fluctuating a fair
bit looking at the episode length
I think it doesn't have enough time to
solve the task not
consistently you can see so I'm going to
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
kill this
here and you can see it's working it's
like it's up to the 19 here just it's
it's fiddly around here cuz like oh is
it figuring it
out I can't
tell let's kill this and then for
comparison we'll run
um 200 mil
steps 50 mil steps even
better this policy should be
substantially easier to port to see as
well this is just a comell
STM which I believe we have we have com
valm and puet
yeah we have Comal TM in puffet already
see so literally
um o the data permute though isn't
there yeah so I might have to screw with
the
data
19 and yeah now you can see the episode
length is around
120 um so that's more
reasonable it has enough time to
complete the
task and I'll be able to even set this
to like 100
all right that's solid that's nice and
stable I'm happy with
that uh I will set this config
to uh I think 100 Mil is pretty
comfortable for this
task we haven't even done a hyper pram
sweep so it'll get better I we'll come
up with like more compelling examples of
this as well but hopefully this
motivates Xander to like try out a few
more things with this
s um I want to mess with the
permute I'm not happy with the day the
way the layout of the data is in this
environment yeah cuz hold
on let me figure this out so this is
important like you want your data to be
in the
format you want your data to be laid out
in memory the way that you're going to
need the data when you go to use
it so what does this happen What Happens
here
so crop size crop size
five. permute
okay so this is Channel's
last we want channels first technically
Channel's last is actually the better
layout for a comp but because puffer net
matches pie torch we will do it this
uh I could also do this in the python
layer but like
it should be easy
it is kind of a gross way to access
memory I have to move this Loop over
cell
types believe I have to move this to the
outside that's kind of gross
right cuz you're like filling in one
layer at a
it might not be that
bad let's just do it and then we'll
Dy oh yeah no this is super
gross you have to redo the bounce
checks Xander has it right here it's
just pytorch has it wrong this bothered
me about pytorch for a
while you really want your com dat to be
Channel's last formatted
and just do it for now and then we'll
see how bad it
is let's do like
this so we do type
X if C so what you do is I think we flip
this if it's less than
zero
or this is just basic
code greater than
zero and then what we
do is
OBS plus plus is
-1 and then we do like this continue
cell
if type was it type
one I think this is the same
logic uh we have a very easy way of
testing that just by compiling it and
seeing if it
works I think this is actually slightly
worse than Xander's original design
because this is a less efficient Loop
order but I think it'll still be fast
and
um yeah I think it'll still be fast and
this makes it easier for p
torch
219 H did I miss a curly
brace anybody see
close open and
close I should get I should get a format
Checker where the heck is it oh I forgot
the opening brace
here yeah there we go
go okay puffer Li ocean porch trash
pickup and then all we got to
view now we just laid out correctly in
memory without the
permute all I have to do is call. float
on
it that should be good
let's see if it still trains or if I
broke it
oops and make sure I didn't miss any
other meeting
scheduled just some slack stuff to
check I don't think I missed any major
meeting
stuff I puffer fish is back indeed
puffer very
good looks like it's
training we will compare the
graphs if this works this should be easy
to port to see
modulo sub type shenanigans
which I think is still pretty easy I
think there's like at most one redundant
copy that you have to do uh for the typ
casting
I think we should just be able to
directly use this policy as
well if it's
good
[Music]
19 come
on look looking for
20 20 is
solved 20 is like full
solved these hyper parameters probably
suck to be fair
so I'm pretty confident this is the same
data from before
though looking at this yeah there we
go I just
refresh yeah there we go
good
graphs now what did I use for uh a com
policy that I can
use let me see what like what
environment did I
use oops
in I'm trying to think what I use
Comin use it in
snake did I use it in MOA I don't think
I used it in
oh
um do I just have that thing and I've
never used
we do weights
agents input
dim what is input
dim oh it's the okay it's the that's
range in divisionals 2 * yeah so
division
um CNN
[Music]
channels we input dim input channels is
five CNN channels is 32
128 and action dim is
four there we
perfect I'll show you the process now
forting a model to see
so we take the last
checkpoint uh puffer a trash pickup
trash pick
up
PT all this does is export the weights
to a flat
format it's like a trivial little script
also tells me how big the net is in this
case it is
150 2
four 2 four five that's the size of the
model and that should
work now the only thing I'm not sure oh
I also have to copy
weights.
bin says
slash that's
assertion index less than equal weight
size
15245 1
15245 uh that's
interesting let me
say what would have caused that
this is obsc Fu con Fu
linear pretty sure this is the same
policy I'll go print it out just to be
sure but let me
see inut D input
channels let
see input d it's 11 and then channnel
got five input channels 32 CNN channels
128 hidden Dam and
four it's fine unless
uh just change something
[Music]
here nope
yeah there it is
one 5
32 wait stride
three that's what I use isn't
it
yeah five by five it's tried three
at right
here well something's definitely wrong
with that because it definitely should
not be out of
here oh I know what it
is don't
I oh no surprisingly I
don't I'm
on input them
what channels CNN channels 32 hidden dim
is 120 action is 4 now this is
absolutely
correct I don't know if I ever tested
this comp to be
here
wait CAC
something's not right
here his OBS doesn't have a
and what do we do Waits make come to
the D input D input
[Music]
channels three
to so no I don't actually use this so
this is
untested so that would make sense why it
is not
working
yep let me see so
weights
agents in width in
height in channels out
channels size Trad so this is this call
looks correct so why does this take up
so many damn
parameters there's what we're going to
do
have
weights we.
size X
correct and now we're on com
2 we're just going to
[Music]
do make com 2D
3x3 ah this hidden dim is
wrong this
linear yeah I think that was
it so it was uh I forgot that this was
not a uh a tested implementation
can I fix this stupid thing this error
drives me nuts cuz I can't ever know
what is a real error
obnoxious I don't want to relaunch this
right now
615 so now we're at make
lstm so let's see what other dims might
be wrong here so make this
Con hidden
3x3 on a 3X3 input
what's
this like kernel
size 3x3 yeah yeah so this is Kernel
size three this is
good and you have
linear oh in features
is CNN channels right
CNN channels to Hidden Dem yeah okay so
this is a little
different whoa whoa
whoa Heap overflow
external this is some like
Jank I should be getting a real error
message here this is just some weird
Jank thing
though I guess it's you know what it is
I see
it yeah
um and obs
C oh this still
fails so if I set this to fault and it
still
fails then there's something in making
the network itself
that's
weird [ __ ] is wrong with this
thing give me a real eror message come
there we
go I can debug as long as I have a real
error
message comp
observations
193 so what was this four grid size 10 4
four
welcome
folks uh only on for a little longer
here I'm just trying to Port this
network to see so that we can run this
demo on the web because we have policies
training on
here oh I know what it
is yeah I didn't test
um yeah I know what it is
ay they're moving
randomly but it does run in C
working if so then we're just going to
do
four
in z e
m total nums
then we'll do
net this is for the
overflow I do not mind these as long as
I get real error messages
according to this this is out of bounds
which is
odd
uh net op should be good
.h num agents times input times
input times num
channels input
float still no oh no that's yeah yeah
it's good that's just uh I have a screwy
system here that just I have to change
some Docker
Flags so yeah now you can see that this
policy is correctly deployed into
C this is running
locally in pure
C these puffers cannot find this last
one they can only see locally so they
don't how to find
it see new
I think I'll leave the rest to Xander
though I think this is a nice start I
think what we're going to do is we're
going to uh here we'll hit escape on
this let's actually fix this so that
this doesn't have memory leaks
waits ignore those Z fults that's
literally just my system if it runs like
this then it's good here I'll show you
that it
test Let's uh if I'm want to do it let's
do it in fast mode
so this is 2 million let me see if he
did the per test right Inc is num
agents I plus equal ink yeah he did this
correct and that's about what I'd expect
I mean it's it could be made a little
faster sure but this is fine four agents
yeah so he has this perfectly
reasonable uh we'll see why it's
dropping some perf I think it'll
actually be maybe a little faster now
that tweaked
it I don't
and then we just have this build script
that does it for you when you just do
um just specify web
web you see that this runs in
browser now all I have to do is get it
onto my main
page so we do is just
copy uh this goes oops actually I don't
have the website buildt on this yet do I
the website is Trivial just HTML CSS
little
up and we need a thumbnail for
it so we'll just
I just get like thumbnails like this for
it
[Music]
and looks
good we're just going
to this is
trash pick
up
now
copy okay so now all I have to do is
add I add this in here nope not
it I'm a web developer
now uh right after rware I'd
say I actually think that uh Xander
wrote me he wrote me a little blur for
this didn't
he makes it
easier love it when contributors don't
make my life
did he
do I don't know if he did the up
controls let me see if he realized if he
remember to do
quick and then how big is this
end GD
plus okay so this should
be
4 400 460 if I'm
correct looks
good
works only thing I got to do other than
that
is you get added to the main page
Xander uh how much work is this I say
right around
here I I kind of do it semi
arbitrarily don't think about it too
much
uh is this in the docks let me fix this
while uh let me just fix this while I'm
here I have the docks open already
okay docs games index
crash pick
up oh that's you on stream yeah fixed uh
let me fix your other thing real quick
as
well yeah that's how easy it is to get
help with puffer right this is half the
reason I stream is you literally get
instant
I thought this C my
credentials one second
okay so this is now
uploaded uh this will be live in a
second so the second
error if I ran it from
Ocean yeah so this is just like in the
wrong spot to find RB uh RB gets set up
in the root of the project um so if you
just put the back end it should work now
and this will be updated in a
second it takes like a minute to
deploy but you'll see it in a second and
I'll double check the trash end and then
we'll call that for the uh for the day
Xander will be happy to see
import
from the ocean
yeah so you're not meant to import that
from arbitary spot uh if you import that
from the root directory it will work
otherwise if you just use puffer lib
normally puffer lib takes care of
importing that for you you don't need to
import s snake that is the underlying
scyon
wrapper this will just give you snake
wherever do I have this in the dock
somewhere or did you just do
this uh I do not have this in the
docs so
yeah the scon ones uh these are
sensitive to Linker paths the python
ones are not the python ones literally
just call the scyon ones they're very
efficient uh you don't need to mess with
this ithon once yourself
works do let me know before I go if that
works I don't does this mean it
worked in testing
okay uh so this is updated on the web
page then o
I neur 3 always takes a second to load
no biggie trash
and I will merge this to 20 as well
right
now no reason not to it's stable
make sure nothing Jank is in
here pick
up
[Music]
module well if you literally just pulled
the latest then you have to
rebuild if you just pulled my latest
code then yeah you have to rebuild it
right like set up build X
in
place I will test it but I think we're
good
if that works let me know and I'm going
to
dinner uh something got slowed down here
I don't know what the
heck maybe I have stuff in the
background
before Oh that's actually probably legit
because of the channel order
change you should be able to get around
that
going wait for this one guy to test it
and then we're going to
dinner it's solid though we get a new uh
new M up on the website
uh uppercase
snake here watch my
screen also yeah you can see it
works from puffer lib ocean
snake
and then also uh if you don't want
to do that from puffer Li
ocean import and creator
creater function and
creater does it make function
make
snake puffer snake or
whatever
make you
see they should all be in the docks as
well let me know if it's not or at least
if it's not clear
yep works now a
okay um I don't think Xander's on stream
so I will chat with him
async uh I've given him some cool stuff
to look at he's got a cool new policy to
look at and see he's got some nice M
changes to look at he's got this thing
training and up on the website so that's
solid for
today
um more M to be integrated over the next
few days I got some Dentistry to
tomorrow which is not going to be fun so
I don't know if I'm going to be doing
stuff here tomorrow and then the day
after is Christmas but I'll be back
shortly after Christmas and there'll be
lots of stuff to do so thanks
folks and uh see you around